من قصر باكنغهام، نسمع
أخبارًا تتعلق بالعائلة المالكة، وقد تم
تشخيص إصابة الملك تشارلز الثالث
بنوع من السرطان، فلننتقل مباشرة إلى
ماكس فوستر من CNN، لذا، ما الذي
تتعلمه جيدًا، فهو يأتي بعد
العلاج الطبي الذي تلقاه الملك أمه
في المستشفى لعلاج تضخم البروستاتا،
تمت ملاحظة مشكلة منفصلة مثيرة للقلق
هناك وفقًا لقصر باكينج وقد
حددت الاختبارات اللاحقة شكلاً من أشكال
السرطان، لذلك يُقال
إن الملك قد بدأ جدولًا
للعلاجات المنتظمة
نصحه الأطباء خلالها  تأجيل
واجبات المواجهة العامة حتى لا نراه
أه طوال هذه الفترة
وسيستمر جلالته في القيام
بأعمال الدولة والأوراق الرسمية
كالمعتاد حتى يظل رئيسًا للدولة
وسيكون قادرًا على تنفيذ تلك
الواجبات الرئيسية ولكننا لن نفعل ذلك.  لن أراه في
الأماكن العامة حتى يشعر الملك بالامتنان
لفريقه الطبي
وإجراءات المستشفى الأخيرة التي جعلت هذا
التشخيص ممكنًا وظل
إيجابيًا وأخبروا عن علاجه
ويتطلع إلى العودة إلى
الواجبات العامة التي اختارها لمشاركة هذا
التشخيص لمنع التكهنات وعلى
أمل أن يساعد ذلك في
فهم الجمهور لأولئك
المتأثرين بالسرطان في جميع أنحاء العالم بالإضافة إلى ذلك،
أخبرني مصدر أنهم لن
يشاركوا أي تفاصيل أكثر دقة في هذه
المرحلة لكنهم يريدون ملاحظة ذلك  إنه
ليس سرطان البروستاتا